let's go next to
uh let's go to herb
from long island herb welcome
hey can you hear me yes i could
all right and thank you for taking my
call um
also for herb it's with a harder h oh
you say herb all right fair enough yeah
yeah with a harder h that's all anyway
uh i do have a quick question for you um
and it's also about trump um
i know you've said before when
republicans
accuse people of things it's actually an
omission of guilt right yeah i mean
listen it sometimes is it's not
literally that way i'm not saying deny
them due process for one but like yes we
should pay attention to that exactly we
should take pause and think about it
correct so
a lot of these republicans are saying
they're worried that
and this is so stupid that democrats
would
assassinate trump like i that's absurd
we all agree that that just isn't going
to happen
however
what is the likeliness of an attempt not
a successful one mind you i'm pretty
confident the secret service would stop
it but an attempt on his life from a
conservative because of the mar-a-lago
raids and these ideas that he might have
dirt on them sort of like an epstein
scenario whether he did or did not get
assassinated i won't get into that but
if that is the case like do you think
that is something that could happen to
trump so
in the next segment
in the email segment today
two people write in with a very similar
idea to what you're saying right now
um i i actually think that from a motive
standpoint it kind of does pass the
sniff test the idea being like hey let's
talk about the left or deep state or
whatever planning to kill trump but
really we're the ones who want to kill
him to get him out of the way so we can
take back the republican party totally
plausible i mean really totally
plausible i just don't think they're
that organized quite frankly so so i
don't i don't actually expect anybody
from the right to try to kill trump
oh yeah no i don't think it would be an
organized thing i think it would just be
like one billionaire trying to do it or
something like that i mean listen if
we're talking about something completely
unorganized and random
of course that could happen there could
be any there could always be some
assassination attempt sure but i mean
it's not really the type of thing we can
predict in a serious way
yeah and i i don't think it would ever
happen can i ask you one quick uh
non-political question i would be honest
yeah so i i know you live in the new
york general region i won't get into
specifics but when it comes to
um food outside of new york what do you
think is like the one food that once you
leave new york you can't get it anywhere
else
once you leave new york you can't get it
anywhere else you won't be able to find
as good of food to give you an example i
think of everyone talks about pizza but
i really think it's bagels you can't get
a good bagel outside of new york in my
opinion
so first of all i was just in montreal
quebec canada it's not the same thing
montreal bagels are their own thing but
i believe that they are just as good as
new york bagels it's just a different
style and to be perfectly frank i mean
there's a lot of places where you can't
get good bagels like once i was in
indiana and i tried getting a bagel and
it was like it should have been illegal
what i was handed um
but like you know in la there's plenty
of good bagels i don't know but i i do
agree with you that like other than a
few places
new york is the bagel place for sure
yeah i'm in ohio right now i live in new
york that's why i have the long island
tag but i'm visiting some family in ohio
and
we had to bring them bagels because they
just don't have them here yeah you know
a crazy story um when uh when in
in college my girlfriend did a study
abroad in spain and this was you know
years ago and there were no bagels
anywhere in madrid except one place
started getting bagels and so she goes
she's like wow this is great i'm you
know if i'm from the northeast of the us
i'll be able to get a bagel she goes and
asks for a bagel can i have cream cheese
on it oh no no cream cheese what what's
that we can we can put mayo on it so but
they they thought that the application
for a bagel was just a smear of
mayonnaise if you can imagine oh oh god
that sounds awf i don't like mayonnaise
to begin with yeah and just as a spread
i mean come on on a sandwich it's one
thing but yeah yeah if it's an additive
okay but as its main course ugh yup no
we're on the same page my friend all
right thank you for the call i'll let
you get to other people i appreciate it
thank you very much very very uh
questions of critical importance i would
say for sure